[Music]
after decades of flat and falling
incomes wages are rising fast this is a
blue-collar boom president Trump's
message on the economy is loud and proud
people are prospering and they have him
to thank the Democrats who want to beat
him say not everyone is winning Virginia
has one of the highest levels of income
inequality in America the church that
runs this food bank says three-quarters
of the people who use it have jobs mr.
Trump the economy is not getting better
for me nor people like myself the
working-class you go to work every day
to support our families Samantha Jacobs
has three children she works hard but
it's not enough
Samantha you work full-time in a school
but you still have to come here why is
that because my family's low-income and
in order to sustain life the way that
I'd like to see fit for us this is
necessary coming to the food pantry to
get things that help to offset what I
spend each month because the wages to
son pay for us to live forget food from
homes and businesses across the state
the view of the issue that could secure
Trump's re-election is ambiguous mr.
Trump I would genuinely like to say
thank you for what you've done
president Trump I believe the economy is
doing great as you say I don't believe
that the people on the bottom rung of
the ladder is doing as well as you think
they are so you guys are brothers you
have very different views on this Steve
you think Trump sort of big talk about
the economy could be enough to bring
things up I definitely do however
blustery Hara bolster boisterous I think
it really translates down the stream to
people Michael other words enough I just
don't I don't think I agree with that
what you're saying that Trump's economy
is open to interpret
that's right yes yeah yeah yeah I think
I think that's fair enough it's open to
open to interpretation but any
administration is open to interpretation
Michael owns the handyman business they
both work for it's going well but he
doesn't put that down to trump I don't
feel that the tax benefits helped me
actually at all I don't even know I
actually talk to my employees I don't
see where it helped them at all either
mr. Trump I am counting on you to keep
your focus on small business to keep the
economy growing and then to win in
November
Polly White and her husband Doug are the
founders of gather a workspace company
with five sites across the state what
they're hearing from the growing number
of small businesses that use them is
that times are good what's different
under Trump I think it's the mood that
optimistic mood because we all know that
the economy was growing under Obama
it was growing slowly but I don't think
people felt it but there's also been
some change in policies it was a tax cut
now there have been trade deals that
have been renegotiated they've been a
number of things that are actually
substantive but I think that they
certainly the optimism is a critical
factor do you think the economy is good
enough universally to secure a Trump win
in 2020 I think that if the economy
keeps growing if nothing happens to
sabotage it in the next six months that
I think Trump has a good chance of
winning again because of the economy
because of the economy people put their
pocketbooks
[Music]
but while those books each tell a very
different story it seems most voters are
in tune with Trump's booming message of
prosperity he's banking on it staying
that way Amanda Walker Sky News Virginia